speaking of mob ties how did you end up
linking up with uh with mob ties and uh
Jay Prince Jr
um I was doing time and uh I had heard
about him I I actually I actually had I
already wanted to work with them you
know so before I met him but I met him
through uh I met him through one of
their artists uh nine Brazen I met him
that's how we like literally Linked In
you know what I'm saying like and I
found out he was going to say a fan of
my music and [ __ ] so I ended up
traveling it up with him and [ __ ] we
clicked instantly
like before before any type of contract
or anything he was there for me you know
saying [ __ ] with me and [ __ ] the long
way I feel like uh people who don't know
this is the guy who discovered Drake
right you know what I'm saying right
I would hope naturally I could just see
Drake just
just randomly jumping on a song out of
nowhere like the back end remix or
something or
has Drake listen to your [ __ ] like is he
a fan is he Tango or at least no
information there's no you guys have a
song together no it'd be cool do you
have something that'd be cool
he's gonna [ __ ] the streets of Jay away
so if the drag vocals came in uh
you know
you know you'll see what will we see
let's see I got a lot of big surprise
going on you know some might say Drake
has a lot to do with the Simpson though
so there might be a clash in uh in mind
States when it comes to females
he is the same God
he's the sixth God and he is the Sim god
he might be the ultimate trick and
that's okay
no no Kanye West said he'll buy a [ __ ]
a house so that's pretty crazy he just
said that in an interview
see let me tell you something that I
believe like I believe that if I believe
that
you you get what you get you get what
you give like so in order for me to do
something for a [ __ ] you got to do
something for me first but she got to
break the ice
she got to come yeah I ain't gonna be
the first one to break the ice and you
ain't gonna just be able to buy me no
ear pods or some [ __ ] or a [ __ ] pair
of Air Forces
no you got to buy me some big [ __ ]
everywhere if you buy me some forces
then I'm gonna buy you some forces yeah
I'm like hey you can't buy me forces and
then you get a bag Bingo that's I
[ __ ] love that precedent we're
setting yeah like like no you buy me a
Rolex I'll buy you a Rolex Bingo like
you can like you can't like you know
what I'm saying you can it's cool to
[ __ ] with them it'll go for anybody if
you buy me a bottle of cologne for
Christmas because you're a broke as [ __ ]
and this is the most unthoughtful Gift
Anyone can get somebody is clone right
then you're gonna get some [ __ ]
perfume bingo I love it you know so you
know you know you get what you give I
love that [ __ ] with me that's my logic